Garden State felt like I'm trying to
think of the chronology because as
scrubs ended completely when you do
Garden State no no I was I was very
young it was it was the um it was I
think after the second or third season
of Scrubs because I I um my my second my
first Hiatus from Scrubs I was in a
production of the of 12th night at the
Dela Court Shakespeare in the park in
New York which had always been a dream
of mine and then I remember while being
there writing Natalie Portman a letter
because
I had she was my first choice
um I didn't have everything she'd say
yes but she was like the archetype of
who I picture yeah and um and I knew
that she had done the seagull there so I
thought oh this will be a good angle I'm
sitting in the same dressing room where
she once sat and I'll write her a very
personal note to saying please consider
the script
um and then she said yes over over that
over that season two so we may have
maybe been after season two or three I
forgot but we shot in 2003 whatever that
was it it uh I mean first of all getting
Natalie Portman and and this is your
directorial debut yeah and I'm young
very young and I remembered at the time
it being it you know you're stepping out
of
your comfort zone to say like I'm on
this successful sitcom everyone knows me
as this guy as this character but I am
going to uh make this movie yeah and
it's something that's very vulnerable
saying like hey here are things I've
dealt with here I mean it's very it was
I had so much clits but when I think
back
um
um I didn't know what I didn't know you
know what I mean yeah but that's
that's another gift too it is is to be I
mean we're right again the time machine
now knowing everything I know and
someone said okay it's 1993. what you're
going to do is I'd say no
crazy no
no full and awful
awful no I'm just gonna stay right here
in this armchair uh because it's great
not to know yeah I didn't know anything
it's a superpower it's a superpower
that's a great way to put it and so and
and amazing things happened I mean it
became a
you know no one wanted to to fund it at
first no one uh knew you know it was it
was a sort of different kind of
screenplay where the third act should go
the character just go off on a quest for
a piece of jewelry we've never heard
about it right it didn't really follow I
was being a little bit
um Brave with with structure and um and
so it was hard to find someone to to to
make it and then I I did and then we had
a a really meaningful Sundance sale and
then it went on to become really
successful how terrifying it all worked
out so well but how terrified just
knowing you how scared were you
I I always try to delineate I've never
been in this film business I've always
been in a let's get in there think of a
couple of ideas okay these seem pretty
good let's get out there and do it
bang crowds seem to like it let's go
what's the next one or crowd didn't like
it well we'll get them tomorrow yeah and
this idea that you're putting that much
time and so much of yourself into
something and you're so young and then
it's all it's coming out yeah it's
coming out how scary it was terrifying
it's but I feel the same way now I have
a new movie coming out it's so you're so
vulnerable but what else can you
do you I mean I think when you when you
choose this career it's like what else
are you going to do you have to you have
to do it you have to make stuff and go
okay here world but in the spirit of not
knowing what I didn't know I had never
I'd never put myself out there scrubs I
was hiding behind the the great Bill
Lawrence I just I just did what he said
to do and improv some jokes and and it
worked but I he was he was the face of
it right in Hollywood at least
um Garden State was the first time
saying hey world uh this these are some
of my thoughts and feelings right um uh
love them or hate them and that so
that's terrifying yeah you said Hey Now
You're gonna listen to me see no you say
hey please look at this no but I
remember at that time you doing a lot of
interviews yeah you're all gonna listen
to me see and you had a big cigar you're
thinking of somebody else I'm thinking
of uh Guys and Dolls you're thinking of
whenever they do like old like movies
parodies
[Laughter]